and with just a few short days before
the all-important midterms we turn to
Larry Sabato for some perspective he's
director of the University of Virginia
Center for politics Larry welcome Thank
You Anthony Larry the first thing I want
to talk about is we're seeing reports of
a surge in early and absentee voting in
some states what if anything do you
think that indicates about but the
potential turnout on a national level
Anthony every indicator that we've seen
suggests that we're headed for a big
turnout for a midterm remember midterms
always have turnouts way below the
presidential election sometimes we go
into the 30s like the last midterm
election in 2014 37 38 percent this time
probably the mid 40s could go beyond
that so that's one of the reasons and
the second is over time Americans are
just really learning to like early
voting it's much more convenient and
they don't have to worry about the
disasters that can happen on an actual
election day either to them or to the
system Larry we saw during the
presidential election polling didn't
exactly pan out so at this point now
what are the factors that you look at be
it some of the information the modelling
that's most reliable to you so that
maybe we do see some of that pan out
I've always told people I mean for
decades look at the polling averages
don't rely on any single poll even your
favorite networks poll that's great it's
wonderful look at it but take them all
together do the averages a number of
internet sites do this for you and look
at that average and say well if it's
within a few points that means it's a
toss-up if it's ten points that means
one candidate is ahead but last-minute
events can change it don't over rely on
polling which is what we all did in 2016
live and learn Larry one of the most
contested races is the race for the
Florida Senate you have the Republican
governor pitting himself against the
Democratic incumbent have you been able
to call this one yet no that's a classic
example of what I was just suggesting
right right now no seriously that the
Democratic incumbent bill Nelson is up
up
Poynter - in the polling averages and
based on what i just said that means
it's a toss-up so we're gonna take
another look on Monday and we'll see
what happens in Florida you have to be
incredibly careful in 2016
almost all of the serious polling and
other indicators we're pointing in the
same direction Hillary Clinton was
supposed to win Donald Trump ended up
winning it by more than a point which in
Florida is a landslide you know Florida
has so many close elections that I'm not
just talking about the 2000 presidential
contest Larry the governor's race there
is really close to Republican Ron de
Santos and and Democrat Andrew Gilliam
to what degree do you think those two
races the Senate race and the governor's
race could affect each other in terms of
coattails they should track pretty
closely we live in a very partisan
polarized era and while there's still a
few voters who will split tickets and
they can make the difference at a close
race the vast majority of people vote
for the same party from the White House
to the courthouse so I think they'll
track closely although in the polling
averages Gilliam the Democratic
candidate for governor has actually been
doing better than bill Nelson the
incumbent u.s. Democratic senator he
Yellen is up about four points but
remember you cannot ignore the
possibility of race becoming important
on Election Day people sometimes don't
tell the truth about what they're doing
to pollsters or even to themselves Larry
we also have Nevada where again it's the
Senate and the governor's race there
where people are watching so closely
what do you expect to happen
yeah I'm this morning I'm a broken
record both of the more ties so whether
both toss-ups look at the polling
averages
I'll tell you though of all the 50
states I trust the polling leased in
Nevada seriously well it's it's very
complicated one of the reasons is 60% or
more of the voters in Nevada vote early
yet and many of them are very well
organized groups like casino workers
Hispanics other groups within the state
and they disproportionately don't report
that voting to those who are trying to
get it
so this goes back to 2010 it's been a
long time coming and people should be
very cautious in that state about
polling we shall see Larry Sabato thank
you thank you
CBS News the live coverage of the
midterm elections on Tuesday begins on
our streaming service CBS n at 5:00 for
central and stay with CBS for a complete
election night coverage starting at 8:00
7:00 central